Các bạn chình truy bắt như phạm đối tượng dính người, lưỡng trương năng đã phải dùng tới phó lại cám để lần theo dấu biết của đối tượng trập dùng sau.
Chị sau tảm dở rời án đối tượng đã bị bắt dữ khi đang cố tủ trên thân nước trập dùng sau.
Và lúc mềm một giờ bà mê phút, nếu mề bà thằng sau, có mọi sát hợp thành tình lâu cây, nhận được tin bảo của anh chào ông sau,
xin nămu yên chính trăm chỉ mì hai, chú tệ thôn xã tạm một xã tạng về việc con trái gọi sau là cháu xe mở đe, mì hai tôi bị hô án xanh nămu yên chính trăm chỉ mì mốt, chú tệ thôn xã tạng hai xã tạng giống mố, mẹn và đầu tiên chào đe từ vong.
Muyến dân xơ bộ văn đầu, giò cháu đe, giống ná cao su, bánh bảo người xanh nên sẽ giả sự việc nếu trên.
Sau khi gây án, xanh bỏ chủ nơi giống xấu và có lỗi hiệu tâm thần, nên gây khó khăn trong ở chiến truy bắt.
Ngay sau khi gần tin bảo, phòng cải sát đình sự có tình là kai khối hợp với các đơn vị nghiệp vụ có tình,
lực lượng có linh quan đã tổ chức khám nhận nhận trường, khám nhận tự thí và khối hợp với con hoàn sát hợp thành,
lực lượng ăn này trở tựa có sợ, dân quân, quân chúng như dân, truy bắt như phạm kè an,
tới khoảng 18 giờ 1 mối phút cùng ngày, cơ quan thong an đã bắt được như phạm sàn khi í đang cố thủ trên thân lốc trong đường xấu.
Chào quả trình truy bắt như phạm, lực lượng trưng năng đã phải dùng tới phalai cam để lần theo dụ bết của đối trường trong đường xấu và thực hiện các vệ pháp như bụt để bảo đảm ảnh quan tính mạng cho lượng lượng tham gia truy tìm,
cũng như lối tường gây an. Hẹn vụ việc đã được cơ quan kè sát đu chá công tình nhau khai, tiếp tục đu chá làm gió để xử luy nhiên theo quy định ở phong lột.